chris is with us in Atlanta Georgia hi
Chris welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave how are you done better than I
deserve what's up yeah I had a question
my wife and I are out of debt and have
always invested every month in mutual
funds
similar to what you talked about and
would like to get into real estate and
just want to know better how to get
comfortable right I understand mutual
funds I'm comfortable with them you know
putting 150 thousand dollars or two
hundred thousand dollars down and you
know one buy for a house this seems a
little overwhelming to me well well it
is it's a lot of money and it's
especially if it's a large percentage of
your world you know I mean if it's a hot
percentage of your net worth going into
that that is nerve-racking would you
make sure you know it makes you just
slow down and be very very wise about it
and so the the typically there's I mean
there's two kinds of fear there's the
kind of fear that says I'm scared of
driving a car because I've never driven
one before or riding a bike because I've
never ridden what ridden one before and
that's a kind of fear that says oh the
more knowledge I have the less fear I'm
gonna have the other kind of fear is
don't touch a hot stove or walk out in
front of a bus which keeps you alive
you're not gonna get over that kind of
fear because you shouldn't it's keeping
you from harm but not understanding a
mutual fund so you don't put money into
it is is a knowledge based or lack of
knowledge based fear and the same thing
with you with the real estate and so the
way to overcome it is just spend time
studying and spend time looking at deals
and don't be in a hurry and don't let
anybody pressure you and don't let
anybody roll their eyes that you don't
know what you're doing you're the guy
standing there with the freaking money
so you just take your time the money and
real estate investing when you get ready
to buy a house as your first for rental
and real estate investment money and
real estate is made primarily at the Buy
okay so you want those you work with an
agent to teach you that or did that be
fine I wouldn't rely exclusively on them
it's a matter of you know it won't hurt
my feelings it might hurt the agents
feelings they might not want to screw
with you
but it wouldn't hurt my feelings if you
walked through 50 houses before you
bought one mm-hmm
but if you did that and make sure you
get it yeah yeah what what area of
Atlanta are you in we're kind of in the
North suburbs like what Alfred oh yeah
kind of the Alpharetta Rockville area
yeah okay all right cool so I mean if
you looked at 50 houses over the next
three years that's an exaggeration but
versus what you know today if you looked
at the numbers looked at the comparable
sales looked at the price per square
foot looked at what they're renting for
look at what what types of rentals
people are looking for one bedroom two
bedroom three bedroom five bedroom in
your area you know you you look at all
these different things then you in a
sense are making a non purchase decision
on a whole bunch of properties but you
get very very familiar with the numbers
and they just start to leak out of your
eyes and your ears at that point versus
right now you know part of the fear
comes you just don't know the numbers
but if you can walk up to a house and go
you know houses in this area going
Fraternity five dollars a foot this
idiots asking for hundred I'm wasting my
time but you vote you looked at 40 of
them and you know that you don't even
have to look it up on the computer I
mean you don't have to have that pull
comp you don't do anything because
you're you know that you've internalized
the information by doing due diligence
and so what you've got to do is look at
a bunch of different things now I'm
saying 50 and I'm saying two years it
doesn't take that many but I'm saying
all of that to make my point that the
more knowledge you have of that house
over there I've looked at six just like
it they all rented for 1,200 bucks and
the only way this deal works is if it
rents for 1,400 so this deal doesn't
work and you can say that in your head
because you have the the base knowledge
from having kicked the
hires a bunch does that make sense yeah
that does make sense and is there a
certain percentage or that's something
you just learned like a percentage of
price value that you want to build a rep
for I try to buy a house on residential
and I try to buy all our property this
way it's very difficult to market that's
this hot I don't go in and tell you
upfront and I haven't bought a property
in a while because we're building a
large large office building and that's
in a concrete holes taking all my money
but but when we were buying property the
last time we bought property which was a
few years back our formula is we try to
buy it for 70 percent of what we think
the actual retail value is which also
means you're gonna just you're gonna
you're gonna make a lot of people mad
with low offers and it's like a
specialty of mine I'm not trying to make
you mad I got money but I can close by
Friday but if you can buy a $200,000
house for a hundred and forty you can
make this work you make it work okay so
that makes sense when you have cash on
hand and you're not we're not in a rush
because I'm trying to move into the
house exactly and I don't care if it
needs I mean if it's got heavy repairs I
might deduct repairs from that as well
but if it's just if I got to run a coat
of paint through it some carpet and tear
the bushes out that's okay I'm spent
five or ten grand on it whatever but if
you got a hundred and fifty when
everything's done in a property that's
worth two hundred most properties I mean
you just poke around it changes from
market to market but you're generally
going to find about 1% a month of value
so a $200,000 house typically about two
grand a month and rent and that's a
rough and dirty and that will change
from market to market so you need to
learn that for your market sometimes
they'll you know they'll run it a factor
higher than that but if you pay cash for
150 for something and you can roll
twenty four thousand off in top-line
minus expenses to get to your net your
net profit on that property in cash on
cash returns in a year you will make
good money you'd be at an 8 to a 10
percent rate of return on your money
before we got to appreciation which also
adds to your the fact that hundred fifty
thousand dollar house is now worth two
hundred you've already made fifty before
we started
and so the appreciation starts to kick
in to your overall rate of return but I
look at a cash-on-cash rate of return
after monthly expenses after annual
expenses I want to be in that 8 to 10
range and that under 80 percent of value
70 percent is what I aim for on a
residential property or a single-family
will typically get me there
is that is that logical yeah that makes
sense it's just about the knowledge like
you said you're comfortable yeah it's
just like okay you know I've driven six
different kinds of sports cars that cost
around fifty thousand dollars and I know
that the Lexus has this I know that the
Beemer has that and and you can start to
make a comparison but until you went and
got in them and drove them and looked at
the you know the horsepower and the the
chassis the suspensions the technology
available on them until you've done some
shopping you you don't know if you're
getting a good deal on the one you're
looking at in comparison and knowledge
of the marketplace is what gives you
that and I do that in anything I'm
buying and I just become an expert on it
and I'll wear people out for a while
until I get my knowledge base up